I was talking this morning about Bob
Seger when you guys covered Turn the
Page why did you guys choose to cover
that song I was driving across the
Golden Gate Bridge up in San Francisco
and I heard uh Seeger's you know the
live version of Turn the Page and I
could just hear James singing that and
the first thing that popped out was just
James would [__] nail this uh vocally
and and just the lyric element I think
it felt like it would speak
on his behalf and and and to the
situation that we were in and there was
just something about the vocals and I
think
earlier on the the cover songs were a
lot about the Rifts and the energy but
later the cover songs became a big part
of how James would interpret them and
how James would tackle it and make him
his own I particularly love the uh lead
that Kirk does on it because uh there's
no saxophone in your version when I was
listening to the song and I heard the
saxophone part and I thought that would
be a great guitar line and I thought it
would be even cooler if I played it on
slide because I'm a big Almond Brothers
fan oh wow man in particular and it was
like my I saw it as my opportunity to
pick up a slide and you know record a
song with slide playing and I'm happy
that I did because I love playing slide
and I love Dwayne Allman well what do
you say boys you want to do turn the
page to start off this morning music
[Music]
foreign
song
[Music]
think about the woman the girl you knew
the night before
[Music]
I must do
when you don't feel much like riding you
wish the trip was through
[Music]
hour again
here I go
[Music]
who pretend it doesn't bother you but
you just want to explore
yeah most times
[Music]
always
here I fall asleep
here I go
yeah I'm playing Star again
there I go
my hair in the spotlight
[Music]
s
goes off the a amplifiers ringing in
your head
cigarette
remembering what she said yeah
watch
watch here I am
on the road again
here I am I am upon the stage
there you go
you're playing Star again
[Music]
I'll be ready
[Applause]
here I go
oh I go
[Applause]
beautiful boys
yeah oh God is that I love that song
yeah
foreign